Nobody expected Us to be a simple slasher
film.
On the surface, it's a movie about evil doppelgängers
and all the horror scenarios you can dream
up with that kind of premise.
Plus scissors.
Scissors suck.
But now that it's here, it's clear that there
are multiple layers that might get lost in
a casual viewing.
So let's to dig into all the small details
it had to offer.
Get ready, because we're un-tethering the
mysteries behind Us.
Spoilers ahead.
If you were paying attention, you might have
noticed that the entire plot of Us was spelled
out in the opening seconds of the film.
After that long title shot with the rabbits,
Us opens on a TV playing a commercial for
the Hands Across America movement.
On either side of the TV are VHS tapes, which
included The Man with Two Brains, The Goonies,
and C.H.U.D.
. It turns out that when you put those all
together, you have the movie Us.
In The Man with Two Brains, Steve Martin stars
as a brain surgeon who telepathically connects
with a disembodied brain in a jar.
Like in Us, it deals with a mental connection
between two physical forms.
"Ladies and gentlemen, I can envision a day
when the brains of brilliant men can be kept
alive in the bodies of dumb people."
In The Goonies, of course, the kids' adventure
leads them underground just like Adelaide
when she follows her doppelgänger into the
tunnels below the surface.
One of the lines that Red says in the climax
of the film actually comes directly from The
Goonies.
She says, "It's our time.
It's our time up there," which echoes one
of Mikey's most famous phrases:
"Down here it's our time.
It's our time down here."
Finally, C.H.U.D., or "Cannibalistic Humanoid
Underground Dwellers", deals with mutants
living in the sewers under New York City who
begin attacking people on the surface.
The parallels there probably don't need much
explanation.
So what was up with all that hand-holding
the Tethereds were into?
In the climax, Red explained a bit of it,
but if you weren't around in the '80s, you
might not be familiar with the crazy charity
stunt that The Washington Post has lovingly
dubbed "the most Eighties thing to happen
in the Eighties."
That charity stunt was Hands Across America,
a 1986 event that tried to raise money for
the homeless by having people stand, hand
in hand, across the entire United States.
The premise was that we're all the same, and
we're all connected, so why not pay $10 to
make a country-wide umbilical with all your
peers?
Connect!
"Haven't seen you guys since"
"Hands across America?"
“That’s what we were just sayin!”
“We almost made it.
Couple breaks in the chain, right?”
“Hands across America!”
Peele has explained in interviews that his
vision for the script was heavily influenced
by that moment, and it definitely shows in
Us.
One of the earliest scenes in the film is
that commercial.
After that, the references pop up everywhere
young Adelaide is wearing a Hands Across America
shirt under her Thriller shirt when she's
abducted, the evil Red uses the movement to
organize her Tethered rebellion, and at the
end, all the Tethered form a similar link
across Santa Cruz maybe even the whole country,
for all we know.
In the original charity event, it was for
the homeless; in Us, it's for the weird psychic
underground clones.
But the message is the same: "We won't be
forgotten anymore."
In keeping with the partial '80s setting of
Us, there's one Easter egg that almost definitely
slipped past anyone who isn't a die-hard fan
of the quintessentially '80s teen vampire
flick The Lost Boys.
And let's be honest...that's pretty much everyone,
right?
“Welcome aboard, Michael!”
Both movies used the Santa Cruz boardwalk
as a filming location, but while The Lost
Boys changed the town's name, Us was open
about the film's setting.
So open, in fact, that during the scenes taking
place in 1986, it alluded to a real-life event
that happened there: the filming of The Lost
Boys.
While young Adelaide is walking with her parents,
her mom tells her dad something along the
lines of "They're filming a movie over by
the carousel."
Peele confirmed in an interview that the line
indeed referenced The Lost Boys, and most
likely this scene of Kiefer Sutherland on
a carousel.
The only way to hit that nail harder on the
head would've been to have young Adelaide
walk past the sexy jazz man.
Oh, what could have been...
You definitely noticed the scissors.
Those golden implements of stabbiness were
everywhere in Us in hands, in bellies, in
that one guy's crotch, in everything.
And there's no doubt that scissors are scary
horror weapons.
They're sharp, they're in practically every
home in the world, and they're an integral
part of the scariest jump scene ever filmed.
[Scissor ghost comin for ya neck]
That's pretty scary, right?
Because scissors are scary.
But in the Peele-iverse, as usual, there's
a dual meaning to those golden scissors.
Like the cutout paper people, the shadows
as the family walks across the beach for the
first time, and the house of mirrors, the
scissors in Us are both separate and the same
simultaneously.
Peele himself explained it best when talking
about the imagery he wanted to create with
the scissors, saying,
"...the inherent duality of two equal objects
that are connected, and an object that's used
to sever or cut, is very important to the
film."
No, wait maybe Tim Heidecker explained it
best:
"Every star has a sister star, a little bit
like two eyeballs.
If you can imagine, if you could see the other
side of my eyeball, you’d see a 360 degree
eyeball."
There are a lot of themes running through
Us, one of which is the horror-centric idea
of creatures from the deep coming up to prey
on surface dwellers.
And the biggest nod to that came in the form
of Jason's Jaws shirt.
There's clearly a lot of Jaws influence on
Us.
Aside from the idea of predators lurking beneath
us, the scenes on the beach are also reminiscent
of Steven Spielberg's classic shark thriller.
Even one of the specific sequences when Adelaide
realizes that Jason is missing and suddenly
sees all the innocent beach fun in a series
of sharp, staccato, sinister moments was pieced
together a lot like the scene in Jaws in which
Chief Brody is on the lookout for a shark
before the big attack.
In an interview with Rolling Stone, Peele
revealed some of the inspiration behind his
latest film, and it comes from an understandable
place The Twilight Zone, one of TV's oldest
and best benchmarks for horror.
In particular, Peele pulled inspiration from
a 1960 episode titled "Mirror Image."
Want to guess what it's about?
Yup evil doppelgängers.
In the episode, a woman at a bus station on
a rainy night sees another person who looks
exactly like her.
As time goes on, she gets more and more agitated
about it, until she's carted off by the police...at
which point it's revealed that she wasn't
crazy after all.
The other woman was actually a mirror image
from another dimension.
"This counterpart, after the two worlds converge,
comes into our world.
And in order to survive, it has to take over."
The obvious connection is there in Us by making
the antagonists mirror images of the main
characters, but Peele no doubt gave this an
extra visual when he put Adelaide's first
meeting with her Tethered in a literal house
of mirrors with a conveniently placed sign
that says "Find yourself" at the front door.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movie details are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.